because what we're seeing around us in
our government is kind of the
performance
of different branches different
structures in our government it's a show
i've referred in the past to court
jester conservatives the conservatives
who pretend to oppose the dominant
liberal regime but they don't really
they just when push comes to shove they
roll over
they put up enough limp opposition to
legitimize the regime but ultimately
they roll over
the same is true when you look at the
media the same is true when you look at
the not just news media but the
entertainment media it's a big
show here's a great example of the show
andrew cuomo is about to win an emmy
award
andrew cuomo last i checked he's not in
any movies
he's not in any sitcoms but he's going
to win an
emmy the international emmy awards are
going to give
andrew cuomo an award quote in
recognition
of his leadership during the covid19
pandemic and his masterful use of
television to inform and calm people
around the world
what television oh because andrew cuomo
went on his brother's show at cnn
and they made jokes with each other and
chris cuomo
tried to cover up his brother's failings
in new york
which led to the directly led to the
deaths of thousands of elderly new
yorkers
made new york the number one leader in
the country
in kovid deaths and as of now the number
two leader
in death rate the only one ahead of him
in death rate is new jersey
another democratic stronghold we'll get
to that in a second
by any measure andrew cuomo did worse on
coronavirus than
pretty much any governor in the whole
country certainly much much worse than
the president
they didn't get the hospitals right
javits center and
the federal hospital ship totally
unnecessary they didn't get the
respirators right they didn't get
anything right
they didn't get a single thing right but
they used the news media
esp specifically cuomo's brother to lie
about the record and the news media gave
him plaudits and now the
entertainment media are going to give
him an award too it's all a big show
disconnected from reality i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you